more blue on the street yes
vote from the age of 16 for sure
free public transport
yes for most people
and the VAT off
so cheaper for everyone
130 on the highway
no not necessary for anything
1 coalition with the VVD
nope
1 coalition with the PvdA Groenlinks yes cooking yourself
yes as in
i wish i had time for it
1 day to the zoo no
and that with my name
higher salary in healthcare yes
1 ban on private planes yes
this also applies to the King
can imagine it for the King
which is hard to be in regular planes
and it has to go somewhere every now and then
free childcare
yes,
but income depends
think of time for the purchase of 1 pet
yesss
yes think about it preferably
first look in the shelter
but also think carefully